your life comes down to your decisions
and if you change your decisions you
will change everything in the scheme of
life hitting the snooze button is not
that big of a deal but here's the thing
about life none of us wake up and say
today is the day i destroy my life what
we do is we kind of check out because it
feels overwhelming or we check out
because we're afraid or we check out
because we start listening to self-doubt
and then we make these teeny tiny
decisions
all day long we don't even realize it
decision to not get up on time a
decision to not eat the right thing a
decision to snap at your kids a decision
to not speak in a meeting a decision to
not look for a job a decision to not
deal with your finances a decision to
not call your parent like whatever it is
all day long these tiny decisions that
take you so far off track and then you
wake up like i did and you look at your
life and you think how the hell did i
get here and more importantly how do you
get back over there and you have no idea
every one of us is one google search
away from a list of instructions that if
you follow any of them it will change
your life
but how do you get out of your head and
stop thinking about what you need to do
and actually do it want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the eight
steps to destroy your laziness
enjoy
have you ever had one of those nights
probably before you started your company
but it where you go in bed and you're
like all right tom that's it
tomorrow
it's the new me
tomorrow
tomorrow i'm gonna get up on time i am
gonna go to the gym
i am gonna look for a job i'm not gonna
drink so much it's gonna be amazing
the new me the future me
let's do this right then you go to bed
and uh you wake up seven hours later and
you're like
i don't feel like you knew me it's the
only
that's the stupidest seat motivation's
garbage it's never there when you need
it
ever
ever ever ever
and so here's what happened to me one
night chris had gone to bed
i had been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems
i we started lean on the house still
facing bankruptcy still fighting like
crazy i was still unemployed
he still they still hadn't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and i was about to turn off the tv and
there on the the tv there was this
rocket launching and i thought oh my
gosh
that
is
it
i am going to launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship like nasa right here
had launched me out of that bed and i'm
gonna move so fast that i don't think
i'm gonna beat my brain
now here's a really interesting point um
i talk a lot about your instincts and
inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that i've done
for the book and all the speaking that i
do what i've discovered that's
fascinating is actually when you set
goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life
your brain helps you what it does is it
opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to work trying
to remind you yeah of that intention
that you said and it's really important
to develop the skill and i say that word
purposefully the skill
of knowing how to hear that inner wisdom
and that intention kicking in
and leaning into it quickly so for me my
brain saying that's it right there
move as fast as a rocket mill
i wanted to change my life and i think
most people that are miserable
or that are that are really like dying
to be great and dying to have more we
want to change we want to
live a better life we want to create
more for our families we want to be
happier
the the desire is there
again it's about how do you go from
knowledge to action so the first thing
in the story that's important is
realizing that the answer was in me
and my mind was telling me pay attention
it could have also been the bourbon
manhattan's that night
anyway the next morning the alarm goes
off and um
i pretended nasa was there
it's the stupidest story i literally
went five four three two one i counted
out loud and then i stood up
and i i'll never forget standing there
in my bedroom it was dark
it was cold it was winter in boston
and for the first time in three months
i had beaten my habit
of hitting the snooze button
i couldn't believe it and i thought wait
a minute
counting backwards that is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard in my entire life
well the next morning i used it again
and it worked the next morning i used it
again and it worked the next morning i
used it again and it worked and then i
started to notice something really
interesting
there were moments all day long
all day long
just like that five second moment in bed
where i knew knowledge what i should do
and if i didn't move within five seconds
my brain would step in and talk me out
of it
every human being has a five second
window might even be shorter
for you have about a five second window
in which you can move from idea to
action before your brain kicks into full
gear
and sabotages
any change in behavior when you
understand the power of a five-second
decision and you understand that you
always have a choice to go from
autopilot to decision maker
everything in your life will change you
will be a different negotiator you will
be different in sales you will be
unstoppable in the gym because you will
realize the amount of garbage that you
put in the way of your hopes of your
dreams of your potential of your
confidence of your courage
everything comes down to the decisions
that you make
we all know what to do
none of us know how to make ourselves do
it
so um
i started researching it why does
something so stupid work
why why does something so silly create
such powerful and profound change well
here's why
the rule is a form of metacognition
metacognition is a fancy pants terms
that means something real simple
you can outsmart your own brain
in furtherance of goals
they're tricks that you can use that
actually outsmart the tricks your brain
plays on you
in furtherance of a higher purpose we
all know this you can you can
restrain yourself
if uh
you're in a situation that calls for it
you can jump into a raging river to save
your dog or your kid
you can direct yourself in ways
if it's important to you
and so the rule what it does is it does
something really remarkable
when you count backwards five four three
two one
what you're actually doing
is you're interrupting what researchers
call habit loops
that get encoded as as closed-loop
patterns in your basal ganglia that's
the part of the brain where your
feelings where your emotions every habit
that you have which is nothing more than
behavior that you repeat that you don't
even think about i've heard it referred
to as a gearbox yeah to shift your
attention from yes
and so when you go five four three two
one it interrupts what's going on here
that's spinning without you thinking and
it moves and awakens
your prefrontal cortex
so when you hit one
your habit has been interrupted so
you've interrupted self-doubt you've
interrupted maybe snapping at your kids
you've interrupted the desire to grab
for a drink you've interrupted uh
procrastination
you've also by counting backwards done
in action
it's awakened your prefrontal cortex
that is the part of the brain that you
need that's awake
when you're changing behavior when
you're learning new things when you hit
one it's also a prompt
so in the language of research uh you'll
hear people talk about um starting
rituals
that is that is something that's proven
to help you learn a new habit the five
second rule when you repeat it becomes a
starting ritual that triggers you to act
with confidence that triggers you that
this is a moment for courage that
triggers you to shift gears and because
you've also done the manual work of
awakening the part of the brain that you
need to change
you've set yourself up for success it
doesn't work if you count up because you
can keep going
and also counting up doesn't require
focus
if you count backwards five four three
two one it again awakens the prefrontal
cortex and it prompts you to move
when you start to use it and then you
read about it you'll see that that it's
being used all over the place they use
it in the armed services in order to
align troops and get them to start an
exercise they use it at elementary
schools five four three two one at big
assemblies to get a huge room full of
kids stop talking simple and interesting
example yeah because
it requires you to focus
it's not a habit it will become a habit
that prompts you to have confidence and
courage but in the beginning it
interrupts patterns of behavior that you
do on autopilot it helps you assert
control and it teaches you how to become
the kind of person that moves from
thinking about something to actually
doing it step number two is understand
the enemy with rory vaden the number one
enemy i think that is working against
people that they don't even realize is
procrastination okay um why do we
procrastinate so there's a number of
reasons there's a number of reasons why
we procrastinate the number one reason
according to psychologists why we
procrastinate is because of
self-criticism
really it's thinking that i won't be
good enough
that i'm not you know i'm not smart
enough i'm not capable so why should i
even bother like this isn't going to
work out for me and and there's a lot of
extraordinary pressure with that but
there's three types of procrastination
yep that
and and most of us are aware only of the
first type so so classic procrastination
is consciously delaying what we know we
should be doing right so i've i have
some bills on the counter i know i
should pay them but i'm tired and i'm
exhausted right so rather than paying
the bills i'm going to like
netflix and chill and like not pay my
bills so that's the first type of
procrastination okay
which is classic procrastination classic
procrastination yeah
the second one is actually one i
identified in my own life um back when
we were doing the research for for this
um which is is funny because you know
when take the stairs came out suddenly
i'm supposed to be like one of the
world's experts or whatever on
procrastination and here i struggle with
procrastination in my own life so
rather
than calling myself a procrastinator i
invented this new term which i really
love because it not only does it more
aptly describe what i struggle with it
also sounds very like academic and
security
and so the term that we coined is
creative
avoidance okay
and creative avoidance is different and
this is something that people do as an
art form creative avoidance is
subconsciously
creating things for yourself to do so
that you can do those things as a means
of feeling productive but really it's a
giant scheme for avoiding doing the
things you know you should be doing
even when you don't feel like doing them
for example for you what's a creative
avoidance i mean email is probably the
is
the the ultimate perpetrator of creative
avoidance right is this like i know i
need to do this other thing i know i
need to work on my book i know i need to
create this process for my business
sales calls yeah you got to deal with a
negative customer service issue you have
to have confront and underperforming an
employee i mean there's i know i gotta
go to the dentist and clean my teeth
yeah the things that you know you need
to do but you want to avoid because it's
painful or it's
frustrating or it's gonna take energy
and time energy yeah and we we blow it
out and we make it we make it way worse
in our mind than it actually is but you
know you can it's wild how we do this
and this is this is where some of the
neuroscience comes in because you know
your your brain is actually working
against you here in in that
if you look at a brain like under brain
scan
the brain loves to complete things
there's a hit of dopamine which is the
chemical you know that's released in
into your body which makes you feel
pleasure when you complete things so um
when you check things off like you
delete an email or you um
you by the way you know this as you
struggle with this if you've ever
completed something that wasn't on your
to-do list and then you added to the
to-do list just so you can cross it off
why because the brain releases and says
oh i'm i feel good i'm accomplishing
things
but really what we're doing is we're
allowing ourselves to engage in the in
the trivial um
in the in the absence of clear intention
we become
strangely loyal and addicted to
meaningless acts of trivia because the
brain is rewarding that behavior people
are literally addicted to email or
clicking on their text or their dms or
social media
they're addicted to it the way you would
be addicted to a substance it's like
it's that you're tied to this chemical
reaction but
ultra performers um the people we study
these people we profile these top 1
percenters
they do things differently and they they
have realized that that success
and greatness
is
not related to the volume of tasks that
you complete but simply the significance
of them and
uh
ultra performers are able to get
themselves to do the things they know
they should be doing even when they
don't feel how do they get themselves to
do that so there's seven seven things
and we can we can rip through them but
you know the metaphor here is take the
stairs okay so so you know that's the
title of the book comes from take the
stairs which is a metaphor for
we just we live in an escalator
mentality world it's easier to gravitate
towards the path of least resistance
towards what is convenient towards what
is comfortable this is an escalator and
yet the truth of success in any endeavor
any industry like when you all the
people that you've interviewed here it's
always the same story it's that they
were able to get themselves to do things
they know they should be doing even when
they don't feel like doing them
i.e take the stairs so
what we're trying to do
is take the stairs it's discipline um
discipline is the antidote to
procrastination yes um
and there are there's seven key
strategies um that you know we can talk
through but but understanding that the
enemy is procrastination and these three
types which we haven't covered the third
one yet but um
procrastination
is uh always there and in fact so the
the third type of procrastination is
called priority dilution
and this is fascinating to study
priority dilution is the chronic
overachievers
form of procrastination
what's different about it is
unlike the first two so classic
procrastination and creative avoidance
um
you know
priority dilution is not about being
lazy or disengaged or distracted but it
is the same net result of of the first
two which is that you you leave the
office or your end your day with your
most significant priorities incomplete
not because you're lazy but because you
allowed your attention to shift to less
significant but perhaps more urgent
tasks uh charles hummel once uh wrote an
essay called the tyranny of the urgent i
believe it was in 1969 and he's talking
about how we
uh are victims to the tyranny of the
urgent and the the more successful you
become the the the more you become a
leader the higher you accelerate in an
organization
your enterprise grows as an entrepreneur
you've got more and more people vying
for your attention the bigger your
personal brand grows you've got more and
more opportunities more distractions
more things coming at you and your
priorities if if left unchecked
naturally dilute right so you gotta yeah
okay so priority dilution
so that's the third type of
procrastination so
you know the question is all right if
procrastination is problem what's the
solution right and i really believe the
solution can be boiled down to one word
and it's a word that nobody likes
um it's discipline yeah and it's not
hard work there's there's a there's a
difference there's a distinction
discipline is doing the things you know
you should be doing
even when you don't feel like doing them
if you can develop the ability to do
that then you literally have unlocked
the ability to do anything in life which
unlocks the ability to achieve virtually
anything step number three is use
laziness to your advantage with gary
vaynerchuk i actually
don't
spend a lot of time on laziness right
actually i mean you think about it i
don't talk about it right you mean in
your content yeah by the way my content
is a manifestation of what's in my mind
so not even in my own mind when i hear
that i appreciate why you say it but
it's so funny it's funny how that just
went through my mind i actually think
being lazy
is a good thing let me explain this is
gonna be an interesting moment
yeah no you're freaking out right i was
gonna say isn't it like
stop watching netflix kind of like
related
stop watching netflix is under the
context of stop using something to
escape your real life
if you don't realize you're trying to
escape your real life don't use netflix
or watching new york let's get very much
into clarification on this episode i
watch the jets for four hours on sundays
i do that
because it allows me to escape
and like it gives me balance to my
insanity but i don't watch the jets on
sunday
to get away from the fact that i hate my
job
and instead of doing something like for
my job i'm gonna use this because
netflix is a seven day a week thing
2k and fortnite is a seven day a week
thing and even sports people that watch
the yankees and the mets and the knicks
and the jets the way i watch the jets
that's why football worked for me one
day a week you know some people use
entertainment
as a reset and a balance to their other
life which is work family
and then other people use con
you know escapism
as a way to just get by because they
hate their life and it's the way for
them not to have to think about it
right
laziness has my attention because i
think if you're lazy you're actually
giving yourself an indication that you
don't like it
so
i think lazy you don't like what
whatever the task at hand for you
you just prop i
you appreciate this and i think you can
see in trash talk i mean i'm never drock
will tell you who's hangs out with me a
lot that between trash talk and the
baseball card show in chicago he's never
seen me happier
i get an incredible thrill
deep inherent happiness from getting
into a car on a 6 a.m on a saturday and
going to find something to buy for three
bucks and sell for a hundred this is not
about the cliche that people say in my
comments of like you didn't make that
much money was the gap you know it's not
all those things i love it
school
i hate it
i am lazy around housework around
logistics
i think quote-unquote laziness
can have a more thoughtful conversation
of actually is it laziness or are you
showing yourself that you don't like
that thing and it becomes a mechanism to
self-awareness i think it's that i think
it's me too that you don't like that
thing i think me too yeah i don't think
you're lazy and i think a little bit of
them you're not lazy i think
i apologize but i want to give you a
compliment you're driving around
hardcore grinding lifting you're not
lazy you just don't get the same thrill
or enjoyment and i think a little bit of
it is
what it is drock is i think we need to
stop apologizing for being lazy all of
us which is probably subconsciously why
i don't talk about it and we need to use
it as an indicator of i don't like that
thing this job this relationship this
school
this startup and then use it as a
starting point to try something else on
the side that eventually can become your
thing
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there step number four is get busy with
grant cardone if you know what day it is
you are not busy enough
i recently heard this week
oh it's monday man it's so hard to get
started on a monday i'm like dude how do
you even know it's monday i don't know
what day it is on wednesday we hear it's
humpback day we're halfway there so it's
friday and it's like oh thank god it's
friday or follow friday or like dude how
do you people know what day it is
you're not busy enough you need to be so
freaking busy that you don't know what
time it is you don't know if it's before
lunch after lunch before dinner after
dinner come on you've had those
productive days
remember the day when you were so
productive you you literally worked
through lunch and dinner and you looked
up at seven o'clock you should have been
home an hour ago and you're like dude i
hadn't had lunch or dinner you know why
because that day you were eating the
marketplace you were consuming the
marketplace because you were active
productive hitting it slamming
creative and completely committed look
that's where you need to be today if you
don't like your financial position in
life you need to get so busy
okay so consumed so obsessed with
activity
that you don't know about the
celebrities that are getting a divorce
you don't have time for o'reilly and his
bad news you don't have time for
anderson cooper coming out telling
everybody he's gay like who cares man
okay why i don't care anderson i don't
care you know why
not cause i'm a gay basher not because
i'm not sensitive
cause i'm too damn busy dude look i
don't know what monday wednesday or
friday are i don't know about saturdays
and sundays i know this create
tremendous amounts of activity so much
activity that you lose track of time
your success is not going to come from
watching tv or looking at a calendar
your success is going to come from
activity from being busy from being
obsessed from being like so into it that
you don't know about oh my gosh it's the
monday morning blues or wednesday
humpback or friday what i don't know
friday what whatever okay get busy step
number five is optimize for fulfillment
and joy with tom bilyeu i'm currently
working on three awesome projects right
now i'm struggling with shifting from
one to the next my urge is to work until
i drop and then crash my world and
health start to fall apart when i do
that any suggestions on steps that i can
take to manage my hectic workload
okay so first of all you're going to
need some rules so we don't want to work
until we crash that doesn't make sense
so we're going to take that off the
table because that's like
running a marathon and saying i'm going
to run the first mile at a four minute
mile pace and
then whatever the rest will take care of
itself that doesn't make any sense
you're going to end up burning out and
odds are that you're not going to end up
finishing so you want to be very
thoughtful about okay i've got this big
project it's going to take i mean
most projects take a very long time the
shorter projects merely are feeding into
a bigger project so assuming that this
is going to take weeks months or years
it doesn't make sense for us to just go
go go go go ignore all the signs that
we're reaching a tipping point go oh god
crash and burn right so we need to
understand what are the signs is it that
you stop having fun
is it that you start losing sleep is it
that you no longer want to eat what are
the signs of the
early
um
overstressed where we're now going into
a point where it's not stress that like
keeps us in the fight and going it's
beginning to deteriorate us okay when we
get that signal and maybe we measure it
in hours per week
in fact that might be a very easy way
for you to tackle it like i know that
for me
93 hours a week is a rate that i can
sustain for the rest of my productive
life i don't know if that's 40 years 50
years whatever but i've been doing it
now for 20 years it's very easy for me
to hit that pace when i'm doing it
towards something that i love and care
about okay so if i know hey i'm working
100 hours 110 hours i know i have a
problem i know i'm now in sprint
territory and i know that i need to be
consciously working to dial that back
because working that much is going to be
deleterious to my health which means it
will be deleterious to my cognition
which means now instead of working 93
hours and getting 93 hours of
productivity i'm working 110 hours and i
might be getting 70 hours of
productivity that is a very bad trade so
you want to be super thoughtful about
just the realities of your cognition and
what's happening on a biological level
when you make those kind of choices to
just push yourself beyond reason so i
would start making you know rules is
like lisa has rules about what time she
stops during the day so unlike me who if
i'm awake i'm other working or working
out monday through friday lisa has
earlier times that she's going to quit
now she still works an obscene amount
but she knows if she doesn't quit a few
hours before going to bed she's going to
have trouble sleeping
so then remember
doing less
is always an option now i'm the go
hardcore the push push push guy
i love hustle porn all of that but i'm
telling you nothing matters more than
fulfillment and joy and if you're
burning yourself out in your stress and
you're crashing that's not joyful
there's no fun to be had way better to
back off
remember that doing less is always an
option meaning you shouldn't feel bad if
you're doing it less you shouldn't be
beating yourself up or kicking yourself
just be honest i'm doing less and i'm
doing it for this reason and as long as
you're being honest with yourself hey
i'm doing less because i don't want to
crash and burn which wouldn't make any
sense because the punch line of life is
not success
it's joint fulfillment that really is
success
so once you
really wrap your head around that then
it should become very easy to feel good
about yourself when you're sincerely
moving towards your goal but being
respectful
of enjoying the ride since getting there
cannot be guaranteed
but the struggle is guaranteed what
we're trying to optimize for is
struggling well
and part of struggling well is knowing
when to back off
so
check yourself if you think that you
might be
not pushing hard because you're
just being a little lazy you want to
procrastinate you have to be honest with
yourself about that but
once you recognize the difference
between you know what i just need the
day off i'm feeling burned out
and
i'm just lazy and i don't want to work
any days like as you begin to figure
that out within yourself
then you'll get to a point where you'll
completely trust yourself when you know
you know what today i need to go easy
because you leave it all out on the
field on all the other days it's very
easy to let yourself off the hook so
earn your credibility with yourself do
what you say you're gonna do prioritize
for fulfillment enjoy not for hours
worked not for hustle porn none of that
optimize for fulfillment and joy step
number six is control your time with ed
milette let me tell you one thing i've
noticed about all the max out performers
that i've interviewed on my program that
i've known throughout my life for the
last 30 years really in business sports
entertainment politics you name it the
elite performers look at time and use
time completely differently than the
people who perform at an average level
and so i want to talk to you about some
tips and strategies today to begin to
think about time and utilize time
differently so let's start out the first
thing i want to tell you about people
who win who max out they are in a much
bigger hurry than the people who are
average and i'm not kidding you when i
say this they're in a bigger hurry to
get to their destination to get to their
outcome their pace is faster they walk
faster they talk faster and their
expectation when they're going to arrive
at their destination is sooner this may
seem like a very small subtle thing but
i want you to evaluate how big of a
hurry are you in
because there's something to be said
about how close you think you are to a
goal
and how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give you an example
of that if you and i started out right
now and we had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we
were going to race each other
we would pace ourselves at a certain
speed in order to maintain that speed
because of the duration of the run so it
was a marathon we'd jog wouldn't we
pretty slowly you certainly wouldn't
sprint 26 miles and so because the
destination because the finish line is
so far away
our pace or our hurry is limited based
on how far away we think we are or when
we'll arrive there but if you and i were
to run a hundred yard dash
would the pace be the same because the
finish line is so much closer we'd run
full speed from the minute we took off
wouldn't we because of the proximity of
how close the finish line is
the people that win
in life don't necessarily have more
vision than you
see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you're going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception you think you're
further away from the outcome and so you
pace yourself like it and you jog all
the time throughout your life the people
that win may have a bigger vision but
they have accurate
depth perception they understand how
close their goals are how close their
outcome is and they're constantly in a
sprint to get there throughout their day
that means consequently they get started
earlier and they finish later they get
up earlier throughout the day they're in
a bigger hurry to get to the places they
need to be because the finish line in
their mind is so much closer i cannot
emphasize this enough to you is just the
pace and the way time shrinks for elite
performers compared to the average i'm
telling you the average performer can
say the same things read the same books
have the same schedule yet the person
who is in a bigger hurry throughout the
day ends up winning the day winning the
week winning the month winning the year
and winning the life
and so please evaluate your pace you
should be in a so much bigger hurry than
everybody around you you almost have
people telling you to slow down a little
bit so that's number one is you've got
to be in a bigger hurry the second thing
is the way we begin our day i'm going to
tell you right now either you're going
to control your time or your time is
going to control you either you are
going to dictate the terms of your life
or you're going to be somebody who
reacts and responds throughout their
life
this device right here can both speed up
time in your life or it can slow it down
it's not always a speed tool so one of
the tips that i've covered before but
not enough people implement that i
promise you is a quality of max
outperformers that relates to their time
is they control it they do not react and
respond they dictate the terms of their
life most of the time and that means
this when you wake up in the morning the
greatest thing you could do for yourself
is not touch or look at this device for
30 minutes to an hour after awakening so
that when you wake up you take control
of your time you control the time you
control the beginning of the day you get
clear you meditate you pray you stretch
you think you go through a gratitude
exercise you control the first 30
minutes of your day it sets a tone that
i'm in charge of my time not what enters
this
if the first thing you do is grab this
this now dictates the term of your day
this controls my day what hits this what
email what text what call hits this what
instagram post hit this this controls me
it controls my time but if you can stay
away from it for the first 30 minutes to
an hour you send a message to your brain
to yourself that you control time that
this day is on your terms and again you
stack up a day a week a month a year
five years of a lifetime of you
controlling and dictating the terms of
your life for just the first 30 minutes
to an hour every day
it will revolutionize your life it'll be
very difficult to do for the first 30
days but after 30 days you'll never have
the desire to do it again you'll
completely flip your life around i'm not
suggesting that all max outperformers
dictate every term of course i respond
of course i react throughout my day it's
not the syntax or context of my day i
control my day there are things
throughout every day where we react and
respond there are conversations where
someone says something to us we clearly
react and respond
but i'm the assessor of my life not the
assessee i assess my life i dictate the
terms of my life i'm not being assessed
and i'm not being dictated to by other
people all the time in my life that's a
huge separator in how people look at
time for maxed out performers the third
thing is this
why is a day only 24 hours
i mean
if the average people in the world or
the majority of people have a 24-hour
day
why does it have to apply to you many
years ago i discovered have you ever had
a day where in four or five hours you
got more in the first four or five hours
done or accomplished in your day than
you had in a normal day you ever have a
four or five hour window a six hour
window like they go i've got so much
done in these six hours it's more than i
get done in an average day and what i
found out was max out elite performers
people that perform at the highest level
they get more done in a six hour window
than most people get done in a day and
here's why most people measure a day by
24 hours so i started to think i was
young in business i was in my early 20s
and one of the things that was held
against me by other people is you're too
young to win you don't have enough
experience you just haven't have enough
days of experience in your life enough
days in business to win i thought well
how can i fix that and here's how you
can fix that and i've adopted this now
for almost 30 years
i want the average people i compete
against to think they have a 24-hour day
my days are six days long
so i want to teach you the concept of
running many days
my day my first day is from 6 a.m to
noon every day that's a full day for me
so i try to get done a full day's work
from 6 a.m to noon because i no longer
have a 24 hour day in my life i have a
six-hour day and so a day to me is that
measure of time it altered the complete
direction of my life it transformed who
i am so now from 6am to noon is a day
that's my first day
every single week 6 a.m to noon monday
morning and what happens in that 6 a.m
to noon i see there's a mental thing we
have i have a whole day to get all these
things done and so we stack and dictate
and schedule our day over that 24 hour
window of time you'd be surprised if you
shrunk the eight to six hours you can
get the same things done in those six
hours you used to get done in 24 from
noon to 6 p.m is my second day and in
that second day i fill it up with the
with a full day's worth of fun memories
meetings phone calls you name it
meetings with my relationships in my
life in that six hour day i pack out
another day from noon to 6 p.m i fill
that day up and my third day is 6 p.m to
midnight and then that's 6 p.m to
midnight same thing my relationships my
meetings my phone calls my emails the
work i do is a third day and so what
happened was when i was in my early 20s
i went from having three days in the
same window of time when the average
person had one and i started to
accomplish triple what the average
person was accomplishing now once again
you stack up three days in 24 hours
over a week a month a year in just one
year i end up with over a thousand days
and i'm competing against people only
have 365.
think about the mind-blowing difference
could be in your life if you ran many
days the rest of your life i'm telling
you right now that my days are six hours
long you'll be the the amount of work
you can get done the amount of
compounding that'll take place in your
life it's gonna blow your mind when you
start looking at your schedule day one
is six a.m to noon day two is noon to 6
p.m day 3 is 6 p.m to midnight your
whole existence is going to change it'll
be kind of fun in the beginning you'll
mess it up but you stack up a week or
two and you do that for a month imagine
that in one month getting 90 days think
about what would happen in your life if
in a month you had 90 days and the rest
of the world the average in your life
imagine that for a second the rest of
the world only had 30.
and you stacked that up over a year or
three years how different would your
life be and i'm telling you
i'm an example of how different your
life would be
i'm an example of what that productivity
and compounding in your life can look
like more fun more memories more
meetings more encounters more
relationships more experiences more
money more achievement more joy more
bliss i'm creating opportunities
constantly so what i do is i shrink the
finish line
so there's sprints all the time and so
because i only have a six hour day i'm
gonna hurry throughout that day i'm not
jogging i'm not walking i'm in a big
hurry and you're gonna be amazed at the
transformation you're like i may never
give you a bigger gift
than the concept of six hour days step
number seven is prioritize like a genius
with brendon burchard let's talk about
how you prioritize things in your life
how you prioritize your tasks your
activities your responsibilities your
obligations your days because you know
it's kind of difficult these days to
prioritize anything because there's so
many people coming at you from left and
right with their notices their messages
their texts their voice messages their
emails begging for your time for your
attention for your energy and most
people i hope this is not you
just give that away so freely
you give all of your attention to
everybody else and to all the world's
false emergencies and to all the world's
needs and all the messages and the texts
and the timelines and all of a sudden
your day is gone and you've had no sense
of of peace or
progress or vitality i hope that's not
you but if you are finding your days
feeling a little frustrating
usually it comes back at some point to
how you are prioritizing things during
those days makes sense right
so how have you been doing this
department i mean really think about it
do you feel like your day's agenda has
been your agenda
or is it somebody else's or do you even
get to shape your agenda do you just
wake up and respond to everybody all day
and that's your priority is just
responding to everybody all day now if
you're in customer service and that's
your job rock on good job keep doing
that but if it's not your job to do
nothing but respond to customers all day
then we've got to have a higher
conversation now and get you back in
control of what your day is about and
the only way to do that is to teach you
some new ways to think about your
prioritization
now you guys know i have lots of online
courses on these types of topics from
the achievement accelerator to the
success accelerator to high performance
academy and high performance academy
masters course lots of deep dive
training on this so in this video all
i'm going to try to do for you is just
give you three simple takeaways three
new ideas maybe a reframe of how to
think about how you prioritize things
and if we do a good job there i think
you'll find tomorrow next week next
month and the rest of this year
you'll be on fire you'll be back on path
now the first idea i have for you is
stop
prioritizing
easy
stop prioritizing easy a lot of people
when they look at their to-do list of
the day they just start working towards
the easy things knocking off the easy
things get they think that's going to
get me some momentum it'll get me into
the day i'll feel like i'm succeeding
and the reality is it's making them less
likely to actually do the things that
count and how do you know this how do
you know if you're guilty of that you
know it if your day feels like there's a
lot of busy work but there's an absence
of your life's work
you know what i mean if you don't feel
like your activities during the day are
really creating to your vitality to the
contributions you want to make with the
world to doing activities and tasks that
you really enjoy whose fault is that is
it the man's is it the governments no
it's like you're setting up your day you
can choose what to do with it maybe you
need to look at doing things that would
support you your health your vibrancy
your joy your real growth and
contribution in a more significant way
if you feel like there's always busy
work but it's not your life's work you
probably prioritize things at a larger
level
maybe incorrectly for you now i don't
know this i can't gauge it i mean i'm
just talking through here now as i look
and as you listen to me
all i can do is encourage you to just
look and say how have i been
prioritizing
have i had a structure have i had a
framework have i had ideas about what's
important to me in the world and i
always run my decision making through
those because if you haven't set that up
this is the time to do that for yourself
first step stop prioritizing easy just
because there's something that's easy to
do does not mean it must be done today
what i would rather you to do is say i
am going to prioritize things today that
will make significant steps forward in
my life these are i just say if the
opposite of stop
or sort of prioritizing easy is to
prioritize
progress
things that actually move the needle of
your life forward things that actually
contribute in ways that you find
meaningful and significant and
fulfilling and you know you deserve that
but sometimes you get caught up right
maybe you've just been caught up in
everybody else's you know hot mess
and your life thus became a hot mess
it's not because you are is that you
were just doing the easy things to
please people because you know that's
easy oh i'm gonna please some people
today but what we need you to do is say
what would significantly move me toward
my dreams today what three things must
happen today that would be real movement
forward not like little checklists our
whole world has gotten so addicted to
little tiny checklists but they're not
doing anything meaningful they're not
checking off i'm living my life you know
so i want you to get back into what
would really progress me today stop
prioritizing easy start prioritizing
progress things that matter i want you
to take on something hard
every
day you do that you'll start to find
yourself
getting a little more confident a little
bit more momentum a little bit more into
that space where you feel like you're
doing things you were meant to do
so second thing is stop prioritizing
false
emergencies
just because someone put it on your
plate today does not mean you need to
reply to it today unless it again is
your job and customer service to reply
back within 24 hours but that is not for
everybody we fall into this false
collective belief that we all have to
reply the text on the second we receive
it then we gotta return the call the
second it came in we don't
what i always tell people you know as
you know being blessed to do what i do
now i mean it's like tens of millions of
people watch these videos and watch my
work every single
year now i mean every single week we
send out two million emails i mean we
talk to a lot of people i'm out on the
road you know
nine months out of the year i'm doing an
event with hundreds of people traveling
from dozens of countries there i talk to
a lot of people i get a lot of feedback
and with that feedback comes a lot of
requests
brennan could you do this for me bernie
could you help that brennan could you
endorse this and i know you get the same
thing
could you help me could you do these
things i need
and you get all of these people asking
you for something
how often are you doing what they're
saying
and what they're asking for
the more that you're doing what the
world tells you or asks of you
frankly the sad thing is the more you
lose your life you lose yourself in it
you you become a pleaser or a placator
you become a person who is just so busy
all the time you're wiped out you know
what i'm talking about
you cannot prioritize other people's
emergencies and here's what you need to
do
learn to say no
prioritizing things are going to move
you forward and everything else
realize that's got to be initial no
and it needs to sound like this here's
what my email literally says when i send
it out to people i say thank you so much
for your request
really appreciate you thinking of me
however while i recognize this is really
important for you today the reality is
my plate has already been full and is
packed with things that i have planned
and prioritized months and months and
months ago i'm executing against a plan
that has been in the works for a very
long time so i'm sorry i can't get your
sudden need fit into that i'm happy to
put you in queue but please realize it's
likely you won't be hearing from me or i
won't be able to participate that or i
won't be able to do xyz whatever they
ask me of for several months if at all
now
people say oh my gosh that'd be hard to
say
i was like you know the first it's true
the first couple times i did that it was
difficult and it made me uncomfortable
it made me feel like you know i wasn't
being helpful to people
but what is helpful to people is you
living your truth
is you serving your highest good
in this world not everybody's speedy
needy request
look when people come to me with an
emergency i i'm okay going back to the
days of self-reliance and saying
you know why is this an emergency for
you all of a sudden did you not know
this was due like yeah i know i knew it
was due
or someone said brandon i need this
tomorrow and here's what i love to say
to them i say tomorrow i said tell you
what when would you need it
and you know if you didn't get it by
this certain day
that like your house would burn down
like major catastrophes oh crap your
world's gonna fall apart i mean the last
minute of the last moment of the real
deadline not when would you like this
not when would you prefer this not when
would it be convenient and nice for you
when would the hit the fan if you didn't
get it and people would start dying you
know
and they'll always say oh well you know
then in that case i really don't need it
for another two weeks
people will always tell you they need
something immediately
one they usually don't need it
two if they do need it they should have
went and got it themselves and been more
prepared
three you owe nothing to anybody but
your own health your own family your own
major true contributions of what you are
and what you want to give to the world
everybody else is a sudden distraction
that is not going to make me popular
saying that and i get it but that's how
you have to do if you really want to
learn how to prioritize you have to
realize every request that comes into
you is a sudden distraction it's not on
your plan
i'm not saying you can't meet it i'm not
saying you can't handle it i'm saying
don't reprioritize your life's work to
handle somebody else's false emergency
what i want you to do is saying what's
important to me today and i want you to
make sure you accomplish and achieve
that and then fit in everyone else's
little requests as is appropriate or
needed or responsible for yourself i
know it's it's difficult when the kids
come in and they throw off a couple
hours of your day because they have this
sudden need or emergency there are real
obligations and responsibilities please
live your life and manage it responsibly
but also
stop
doing that little thing that everyone
does
giving away all their pieces of the day
to anyone who asks and suddenly they
find themselves broke with time
broke with energy broke fulfilling
everybody else and never having lived
their own life
prioritize
real deadlines real responsibilities
real obligations and prioritize
everything else as a sudden distraction
and you will start finding yourself
leaping forward last one's much more
positive you're like geez brenda i
thought you were like the positivity guy
and the motivation guy you know last
one's a lot more easy and more palpable
for you maybe or palatable i guess i
would say and that is start prioritizing
freedom
start prioritizing your ability to gain
more emotional freedom physical freedom
social freedom financial freedom time
freedom i love looking at people's
actual day agenda and i say where in
here is freedom
where is your ability to do a 20-minute
meditation because it's going to make
you feel alive and and back and grounded
connected
you don't have anything where you
prioritize your own psychology today
where are you thinking about your
strategic plan where are you thinking
about the vision for your life where are
you daydreaming and napping if you need
to do that were you prioritizing your
physical energy because if you can't
have physical freedom from fatigue
you'll accomplish a whole lot more even
if your priorities are not always in
whack like if you absolutely have the
financial i mean
the physical freedom i should say
to be able to
just cultivate energy on choice
that comes from having prioritized
health during the day what about time
freedom i mean i think we're all after
time freedom so where are the breaks in
your day and what are you doing with
those breaks are you reading stupid
trashy magazines are you sitting and
dreaming about how you can contribute
more what your next art is what the next
major thing is that you want to give or
serve or be or develop as a human you
have the ability to make your days
magical and i wish someone told me that
when i was younger they said hey look
you are the architect of your day how
magical do you really want it to be make
that decision today and you will start
to experience a lot more of what we call
the charged life and step number eight
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is organize your mind with j
shetty now i want you to take a moment
to just jot down what are the decisions
you make every morning before you've got
out of bed
before you get into your commute or
start your work day chances are you
spend a lot of time thinking about what
to wear what to eat that morning you
might even think about what to eat for
lunch what to eat for dinner you might
be wondering around what movie you're
going to watch tonight what episode of
which show you're going to watch when
you get back you may even be thinking
about what meeting do i have what person
do i have to connect with today what do
i even have to do today these are very
common things for a lot of us the
concept of decision fatigue teaches us
that so many of us are making so many
insignificant decisions in the morning
that by the time we start our work day
we're already exhausted from making
decisions we overthink about the smaller
things that should be easy and now we
have no energy for the bigger things
that do require our attention and our
awareness i want you to create a table
of decisions to make the night before
and decisions to make the day of what
that's going to help you do is give you
something to focus on the night before
so you can be prepared and well ahead of
schedule before the next day and be
really clear about what you can only do
on that day now the night before you
want to be doing that either at the end
of your work day or just after dinner
the reason is because at the end of your
work day you can set yourself up for
success the next day
for those of you that want to leave it
till after dinner the reason why i say
after is because we make better
decisions when we're eaten and when
we've nourished so what we're
essentially doing with decision fatigue
is that we're stopping ourselves from
over thinking about the smaller
irrelevant to some degree insignificant
decisions to the more significant
decisions
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact and to grow and do amazing
things
you know you can do amazing things
what's missing discipline
there's just a lack of follow-through
it's the constant start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me
the only one of the only reasons why i'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and i've had any you know success in
social media
is because i just was disciplined that i
just kept making videos
one of the things i love sharing is
my journey of youtube because i was not
an overnight success story
every month almost i'll post to
my socials of how i grew month over
month
year over year on youtube
and
in the first five years i had 7 000
subscribers or so
so five years in five years in of making
content
seven thousand subscribers
a lot of you already ahead of that a lot
of you
could get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
i
just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be
as slow as me you know i took i took a
long time
and i had a lot of issues i was
shy and insecure and introverted and
felt like you had to be
you know type a personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
beliefs all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and i really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me
i remember sitting down at a
um
florida outlet mall
and i was sitting there with uh with a
friend and nina was going shopping
and uh
we spent half an hour at a at a
starbucks there while she was shopping
and he said i'm going to be the next
gary vee
of my mystery you know he's in music i'm
going to be the next gary v in music
and uh
you're going to keep doing your thing
like let's me you know let's let's keep
in touch and see how we do and how we
grow and he posted
you know three or four years later
on his instagram and he said you know
three or four years three or four years
ago i met evan carmichael at this
outlet mall in florida he had our
picture as the
as the post
and i told him i was going to be the
next gary vee for music and he's going
to do keep doing his thing and and evan
went on and did his thing
and i stopped
i didn't have the success that i said i
was going to have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more talent than i do
and he's super talented in music and
just better camera presence
more energy
uh
more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail he had
all of this stuff and and like a warm
amazing human who cares and wants to
serve and wants to see musicians make
money and turn their art into something
amazing right like he had all of this
stuff
all of it
the only thing he lacked was discipline
and he didn't follow through
and and i see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the
lack of
because you're not motivated you stop
and lack of motivation isn't a good
enough reason you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you how do you stay disciplined how do
you stay focused when you're not getting
results when you're not seeing the wins
how do you stay disciplined okay so let
me give you a couple things first is
having a really powerful morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day
no matter how great today is tomorrow's
a new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event you watch a
video get all inspired and you expect it
to last and then tomorrow you wake up
it's like oh how come i don't feel the
same way as i did yesterday and then
that creates a cycle of procrastination
instead of actually following through so
the morning routine really matters what
is it that gets you feel inspired
motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off
and have a much better day for me
two of the things that i find the most
valuable are in my morning routine one
is music so i put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your
state put on songs that make you move
that make you dance and make you wanna
just change your state cause you wake up
tired and no energy like let's go we
gotta demand excellence from ourselves
and so music is the fastest way to get
your body into a different state um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day
i walk i go to tim hortons i grab a cup
of coffee and spend you know two bucks
on it and i think about my day how do i
want my day to go what how do i want to
be intentional about the day so we're
not waking up like an accident most
people wake up like an accident fall
into their day look at other people you
load your phone you write other people's
agenda for your time and then you don't
follow through and so
having that as part of my morning
routine really helps me so what is your
morning routine the most important thing
that you need to do is the thing that
makes you feel important
vibrant that today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happened
that's why i make so many videos too
there's content for you every day if you
need me in your life or you need the
people that i post on your there's
something every single day for you
across my channels
so there's no excuse for you not to get
the
the
inspiration and the motivation and the
tactics that you need to make your
dreams happen so that's step number one
is have have a powerful morning routine
step number two is create a calendar you
know what's in your calendar i'm making
videos today because it's in my calendar
today's a tuesday when i'm recording
this and tuesday is my youtube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening my
business
uh
you know right now where we're at um
my wife's parents house and they're
delivering a couch
you can see that they're delivering a
couch here
it's delivering a couch and they're
helping i'm here making content because
tuesday's my youtube day
you know there's so many other things i
could be doing right now
if i was left to my own devices i'd say
i have something more important to do i
need to be doing x
but because this has been scheduled in
my calendar i'm going to follow through
and make videos
how have i made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially for the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do i'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later i'm still afraid to make
videos why because i want these videos
to be the best i've ever done because i
want to show up with more care more
heart more passion
i hope that this is a video that forces
you you know to take some kind of action
i want it to be the best one that i've
done and so i i mini procrastinate
before making videos on a tuesday every
week i have a mini mini procrastination
the only difference is my
procrastination is you know 10 minutes
instead of
days
10 days and then it doesn't happen
right
and so whatever you are procrastinating
on that you know is important that
you're just afraid of
you put in your calendar and you block
off time
and
that allows you the creativity and the
space
and suffocates the excuses
for you not to follow through
and then step number three so one have a
morning routine right that sets you up
to create that gets you inspired makes
you feel like you're important today's
gonna matter
two you create a schedule for when
you're gonna do the things especially
the scary things on your list and then
three you have to teach yourself that
you do the things that are in your
calendar
you said you're gonna do it you put in
your calendar you get it done
even if you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow
or you can change your calendar for next
week
but don't
trust yourself or listen to yourself
when you're feeling low
when you're feeling overwhelmed and you
said you were going to do it
you have to go up and do it to teach
yourself because what happens is the
next time you say you're going to do
something you put in your calendar
you don't trust that you're going to
follow through because you haven't
followed through the last 20 times
so be very careful about what you put
into your calendar and then when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline
again you've got the heart you've got
the creativity you've got the passion
you've got the willingness to serve you
know you can do more you want to create
an amazing life yourself your family the
people around you like you know you've
got this thing you know you've got this
thing i don't need to tell you this you
know that you've got something amazing
inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough
you have to stop jumping from high to
high to high and and wondering why you
don't feel motivated today there's
nothing wrong with you this is
normal discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to apply the high five habit with
mel robbins check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i hope your business goes bankrupt
evan evan you're a terrible person i
spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way